Russia's war of aggression grinds on
against Ukraine and over the last weeks
and months we have seen Fierce fighting
in and around bakmud and what we see is
that Russia is throwing on more troops
more forces and what Russia lacks in
quality they try to make up in quantity
they have suffered big losses but at the
same time we can not rule out that
um
may eventually fall in the coming days
and therefore it is also important to
highlight that this does
not necessarily uh reflect any turning
point of the war and and
it just highlights that we should not
underestimate Russia we must continue to
provide support to Ukraine so what we do
know
is that there was an attack against the
north stream pipelines an act of
sabotage but we have not been able to
determine who was behind there are
ongoing National investigations and I
think it's a right to wait until those
are finalized before we send him more
about who was behind it demonstrates the
importance of protecting our critical
undersea infrastructure because we have
thousands of kilometers of gas pipelines
of oil pipelines of power grids and also
of course all the internet cables and
all of these uh infrastructure is
critical for our societies NATO has
addressed this for many years but after
the attacks against the north stream
pipelines we have stepped up we have
established a cell at the NATO
headquarters to coordinate efforts among
NATO allies to share more information to
work with the private sector that often
owns this infrastructure and to do more
to minimize the risk and increase the
protection of critical undersea
infrastructure
School